alors est-ce que le télétravail est là
pour durer j'en parle avec diane
gabrielle tremblay économiste et
professeur à l'école des sciences de
l'administration de l'université tel bon
soir madame tremblay bonsoir
alors la crise de la coved a forcé cette
révolution du travail mais ce que c'est
là pour rester il ya seulement huit pour
cent des québécois qui veulent revenir à
100% au bureau effectivement je pense
que pendant cette crise au fond on l'a
fait la preuve que c'était possible de
télé travailler et d'être performant au
travail a beaucoup d'organisations qui
refusait tout le travail à leurs
salariés beaucoup de sérieux aux frères
qui aurait souhaité je travaille à qui
on dit que ce n'était pas possible
je pense que maintenant la preuve est
faire et donc à mon avis on va continuer
on va se trouver dans une situation
mixte sans doute c'est à dire qu'on
aurait pu considérer si vous n'avez pas
duré très longtemps serait peut être une
petite parenthèse on fait comme avant on
pourrait aussi au contraire si jamais
c'était devenu nettement pire et puis
que bon vous ne pas sortir et tout alors
on aurait pu parler d'une rupture
complète et vraiment on insiste comme
vous évoquiez quelques entreprises vont
insister pour que leurs salariés restent
vraiment toujours à domicile
personnellement je pense qu'on va plutôt
aller vers une situation intermédiaire
en fait d'une situation mix où les gens
viendront au bureau de temps en temps et
feront aussi du télétravail
c'est une tendance importante est ce
qu'on sait quel pourcentage de la
population s'est mise au travail du
travail avec cette crise là oui en fait
évidemment il ya des gens qui ne peuvent
pas faire du télétravail on l'a bien
constaté dans la santé les policiers et
c'est donc ce que statistique canada a
évalué c'est qu'en mars et surtout avril
mais on était 40 pour cent de la
population canadienne québécoise en
télétravail c'est à peu près le même
taux pour trouve ailleurs alors qu'on
partait de 10% auparavant
et plutôt des gens qui était
occasionnellement à temps en télétravail
on entend souvent que le télétravail est
une bonne façon de concilier le travail
et la vie personnelle la vie familiale
mais est ce que c est ce que c'est vrai
en fait un directeur alors qu'il ne faut
pas s'imaginer comme jeu parfois vu des
photos là dans les médias notamment des
leaders américains qui parlait personnes
en télétravail
qui plaçait une femme devant leur fille
nateur avec un bébé sur les genoux alors
bon bien sûr malheureusement il ya des
gens qui l'ont vécu un peu ces derniers
mois parce que les services de garde les
écoles étaient fermées mais normalement
le télétravail ça veut quand même dire
séparer la vie professionnelle et la vie
familiale
en fait ça facilite au fond où la vie
familiale la ponctuation fallait parce
que essentiellement ça réduit notre
table déplacement pour certaines
personnes ça peut vouloir dire 10 ou 12
heures par semaine en fait que ces
personnes gagnent et donc de ce point de
vue là c'est avantageux c'est aussi
intéressant du point de vue de la
flexibilité des horaires de travail sauf
si on est en centre d'appels par exemple
l'on va faire une phase 1 de notre
employeur ont insisté pour qu'on fasse
de 9 à 5
mais par contre on peut avoir des
horaires plus flexibles donc tout ça mis
ensemble plus grande la plus grande
flexibilité
pas de temps de déplacement c'est ce qui
fait que ça fatigue et de la
conciliation vie personnelle familiale
et professionnelle
oui évidemment ga télétravail et là il
ya l'école à la maison qui s'est ajoutée
là dessus au cours des derniers mois qui
ne sera peut-être pas là au cours des
prochains mois autres quand on peut le
souhaiter avec la gestion des tâches
familiales ménagères est ce qu on peut
se demander justement est ce que les
hommes et les femmes sont égaux sur le
plan du télétravail
alors tout est une question qui est un
peu particulière dans le contexte actuel
on l'a pas encore de données de
recherche tout à fait fiable mais il
semble quand même effectivement beaucoup
d'hommes sont retournés au travail ou en
tout cas ont eu des activités
professionnelles alors que les fans sont
restés davantage dans le dos mais alors
qu'elles devaient aussi assuré au fond
s'occuper des enfants mais l'ensemble de
la maison
par contre en temps normal justement où
les enfants ne seraient pas à la maison
ce que l'on observe et ya des chercheurs
qui avait indiqué que les femmes avaient
peut-être plus de difficultés à séparer
le professionnel le domestique le
familia en fait c'est en grande bretagne
nous serons les observer dans les
recherches au québec c'est parfois au
début il ya un peu de confusion il ya un
peu de mélange dans les frontières entre
les membres ne sont pas très clair mais
très rapidement au fil du temps les
femmes comme les hommes arrivent assez
paris partons aussi par le passé les
hommes parfois pouvait davantage
bénéficier du télétravail
tout simplement parce qu'ils étaient
dans les catégories professionnelles où
c'est possible
les cadres les professionnels beaucoup
d'employeurs permettait à ces catégories
de faire du télétravail
mais là on a vu ça a été possible y
compris dans des catégories d'agents
bureau de secrétaire et autres donc a
priori a pas de raisons pour lesquelles
les femmes dont serait exclu du
télétravail comme certains l'ont parfois
indiqué sauf bien sûr celles qui sont
dans les tâches santé commerce de détail
mais il ya aussi les catégories
professionnelles masculine ou le
télétravail ne peut pas s'appliquer
donc je pense que en fait va falloir
quand même mettre des balises assurer
justement que les femmes par exemple ne
sont pas oubliés dans les organisations
si elle décide de faire du télétravail
mais on pourrait dire la même chose pour
les hommes
bien que si à des réseaux masculin dans
une organisation et que les femmes ne
sont pas présents elles sont de fait
moins visibles alors c'était cet aspect
là au fond qu'il faut s'assurer fois il
faut y être attentive les gestionnaires
doivent être intentées à céret on peut
se demander si les espaces de coworking
vont devenir l'avenir du télétravail moi
je pense qu elle on aurait pu penser
qu'ils auraient pu fermer beaucoup
d'entre eux d'ailleurs son produit
beaucoup de questions parce qu'à
l'origine c'était des espaces ouverts si
la mise en place
comme beaucoup de grandes entreprises
qui ont des airs ouvert alors ça c'est
un peu remis en question par contre moi
j'ai pas une enquête là-dessus récemment
à l'extérieur de montréal on avait
beaucoup plus d espace de coworking où
il y avait quand même des bureaux fermés
à l'intérieur donc on partage des
ressources des espaces communs mais on a
quand même par un bureau fermé
je pense que probablement on va aller
vers des combinaisons de ce type là et
des personnes qui seraient en
télétravail par exemple quatre jours
semaine à l'extérieur de montréal
pourrait peut-être avoir envie de voir
des gens parce que c'est quand même ça
aussi la dimension au milieu social du
milieu de travail les relations avec les
collègues
c'est quelque chose qui est important
pour beaucoup de gens donc vous évoquez
le fait que les gens ne veulent pas
retourner à plein temps mais par contre
pour beaucoup de gens l'idéal ce serait
quand même une deux ou trois journées en
télétravail est aussi un certain nombre
de journées au bureau l'avenir
évidemment du travail va continuer de se
de ce cri remercie beaucoup madame
tremblay pour cette entrevue ça m'a fait
plaisir